Translator: Joseph Geni
Reviewer: Morton Bast
(Music)
(Applause)
Thank you.
Hi, everybody.
Ban-gap-seum-ni-da.
I'd like to share with you a little bit of me
playing my life.
I might look successful and happy
being in front of you today,
but I once suffered from severe depression
and was in total despair.
The violin, which meant everything to me,
became a grave burden on me.
Although many people tried to comfort and encourage me,
their words sounded like meaningless noise.
When I was just about to give everything up
after years of suffering,
I started to rediscover the true power of music.
(Music)
In the midst of hardship,
it was the music that gave me -- that restored my soul.
The comfort the music gave me
was just indescribable,
and it was a real eye-opening experience for me too,
and it totally changed my perspective on life
and set me free from the pressure
of becoming a successful violinist.
Do you feel like you are all alone?
I hope that this piece will touch and heal your heart,
as it did for me.
(Music)
(Applause)
Thank you.
Now, I use my music to reach people's hearts
and have found there are no boundaries.
My audience is anyone who is here to listen,
even those who are not familiar with classical music.
I not only play at the prestigious classical concert halls
like Carnegie Hall and Kennedy Center,
but also hospitals, churches, prisons,
and restricted facilities for leprosy patients,
just to mention a few.
Now, with my last piece, I'd like to show you
that classical music can be so much fun, exciting,
and that it can rock you.
Let me introduce you to my brand new project,
"Baroque in Rock,"
which became a golden disc most recently.
It's such an honor for me.
I think, while I'm enjoying my life as a happy musician,
I'm earning a lot more recognition than I've ever imagined.
But it's now your turn.
Changing your perspectives
will not only transform you but also the whole world.
Just play your life with all you have,
and share it with the world.
I really look forward to witnessing
a transforming world by you, TEDsters.
Play your life, and stay tuned.
(Music)
(Applause)